well now the rest of that extraordinary
interview with mickey rourke he was
moved to tears discussing the war in
ukraine and when last night's show ended
rather abruptly i said that we would
keep the conversation going and we would
then show the viewers later what we said
to each other and it turned out to be a
remarkable exchange
i mean mickey when you talk so
powerfully about ukraine and what's
happened to the people there
you must think back to your experience
of meeting putin
and question whether he really did have
the ability to be empathetic
i saw it with my i saw people don't want
to hear it i saw it with my own eyes
i saw it the way he treated me okay but
being
something changed or
and all this mayhem and this death and
this killing
i didn't see that when i was at the
children's home
with the little kids that all had cancer
and and he was so genuine and empathetic
and and and
i saw
someone who really cared now people
might be mad at me for saying something
like that but i saw him at in 214. right
now what's going on right now i don't
i don't
i think i don't believe in that
war i think it's
it's it's terrible it's it's my best
friend in the world who i love more than
anybody is from ukraine he just got his
family out of nicolaive and
you know every day when dima who's
ukrainian comes to work with me
you know the first thing i say to him is
how how how's your mother house how's
your family house because
you know when demon knocks on the door
to come to work
what's going through my mind before he
opens the door is
he's going to tell me something
not good
what is your message for putin
if you had a chance to give it to him
you're not going to live forever
look at all look at you know
peter the great napoleon with the
what what happened to them trying to get
more and more and more and just you know
you've got your power your money just
live your life and
you know let these people in ukraine be
independent in a
democratic society they want to live in
and
and just stop today stop now not
tomorrow just stop right now
mickey you recently posted a statue of
liberty uh crying it was an image of
statutory crying in tears
and you captioned it with a lot of truth
what did you mean by that
well because they call it the united
states of america it's it's it's now the
divided states of america
and there's one big reason for that but
i'm not going to go into it because i
don't need another visit from the secret
service
when did you have one before
oh about six months ago why
take a wild guess
was it because of something he said
about president trump
yeah
what did you say about him
just the truth
which is what
read my mind
and the secret service actually came to
see you
oh yeah
and what do they say
a lot
and that's just way over my head so i
got nothing to say anymore about nothing
are you still trying to
they're still trying to fit they're
still trying to figure out what happened
to kennedy's brain
all
right
are you sad mickey about what's
happening to america
no because i've never felt comfortably
comfortable in this country to begin
with i've always enjoyed the uk
i've always enjoyed france i've always
enjoyed italy
i've always enjoyed russia uh i haven't
been to the ukraine i can't go right now
but i i've never really felt
comfortable in my own country really
i've always liked other countries better
well do you think you're never here
what do you feel like
italy i think i'm right in saying mickey
that joe biden was the first time you'd
voted for any president are you what do
you think of how he's doing
it's he's doing
all he can do with the mess that he's
got on his hands
is he too old for the job do you think i
know i don't think it has anything to do
with his age i think it's going to take
another
after the last
thing it's going to take another 30
years for this country to
straighten itself out
if it ever can again
it's divided you can feel it
i've lost friends over it
uh
but i'm not going to be outspoken about
it anymore i don't i don't need the fbi
to call me up and tell me that some
trump fanaticals got me on a hit list
and all that oh you know what
i'm moving to texas
my place is going to be fortified like
nobody's business
and if somebody wants to come through my
gates it's going to be the last two
steps they ever make mickey i wanted to
talk to you also about what happened to
your friend johnny depp what did you
think of that case and and
the fact that in the end he won it
well you know i i know i know johnny for
many years but i i don't really know him
intimately
all i could say is i was in a situation
one time where i got blamed for
something that i didn't do
it cost me movie jobs for several years
and it caused me a bad reputation and
finally
the truth came out but the truth came
out after
i lost movies and i lost jobs and
and so i felt died for somebody that
uh
is getting trying to get chopped down by
some gold digger you know
you think that's what she was
absolutely
absolutely
you have a russian model girlfriend i
believe is that going well no no no no
that was several years ago
are you are you single now
i've been single for seven years
really
yeah do you like it that way
at the first four years it was really
lonely um
but i realized that i couldn't keep
i couldn't keep
going out with
women that
we're gonna
if i ever have a relationship ever again
i hope maybe somebody comes in my life
that i can trust
how many times how many times have you
been would you say properly in love in
your life
once
once who with
you know with
well you tell me
you tell me
[Laughter]
i'll guess it was carrie
yes it was
she was the love of your life that was
23 years ago we haven't seen each other
or spoke
if you did see it what would you say
mickey
nothing
do you have any regrets about the way it
all ended
i've got a lot of regrets about a lot of
things you know so
that contradicts that
frank sinatra song
yeah i did it my i did it my way but
he says too few too few to mention i got
too many to remember
well says the next mickey opens up on
his close friendship with tupac 25 years
since the rapper's shocking death
we had a lot of stuff in common
uh
and we we loved each other you know
deeply
and uh
i think about them all the time
welcome back now to the final part of
this explosive interview that's making
headlines across the planet hollywood's
comeback king mickey rourke very much
uncensored
what do you make of the way tyson fury
handles himself the the world
heavyweight i love i love tyson fury he
has so much ability it's not even funny
do you think he'll fight again he says
he's given up
every every fighter says he's giving
they've given up
and they all come back
how do you rate him in the pantheon of
heavyweight champs
excuse me how do you rate tyson in the
list of the greatest ever
uh one of the very best ever because of
his size
but he's also a very fluid fighter he he
uses faints
he uses his jab
he's very intelligent he's got a very
extremely high boxing iq and it's in his
blood
and he he knows how to pace himself
plus he takes one hell of a punch and
gets back up
who's when you were boxing mickey
obviously you got to know a lot of
boxers you've got to know the art of
boxing you're a very good boxer yourself
who is the boxer in history of any
weight
you would have least wanted to get in
the ring with
at their peak
well there's two different things there
there's there's
there's like a great fighter
like linux lewis
that
is eventually going to catch you
because of his height his reach his
boxing iq
and then there's the first four or five
rounds with mike tyson yeah
you know
um
one fighter i i admire so much is from
your country is was henry cooper oh yeah
yeah yeah
well he could have beaten our league
couldn't he he had a chance
well he actually did if the gloves
didn't get cut the time would have ran
out yeah that's what i mean yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah do you steal bulks mickey
and you yes i do
yeah
just i'm trying to decide i'm trying to
decide if i'm gonna have one last one
mike tyson is still fighting why don't
you why don't you finally get in the
ring with tyson
test your three i
i don't mess around with anything over
220 pounds
[Laughter]
how is uh how is your feud with robert
de niro going is that showing any sign
of
there there's no views it's just a lot
of
people try to stir up you know i have
i have nothing
i have no feeling whatsoever on the
subject
who is the greatest actor you've ever
seen
aside from myself aside from yourself
no
i would say marlon brando monty cliff
richard harris
uh
who
charles branson
he was great he was great actually
but you are a great actor mickey i mean
you are one of the great actors when you
were on your absolute a game you were up
there with any of the grades i think
well i'm back on my a-game
you think you still are
no i know i i know i am
are you considering any any roles at the
moment you think could show us
well i i had i just had a great
experience with roman polanski
uh i'm going to go over to paris to work
with uh jean renau and if it's a casel
and so we've got some very interesting
projects
lined up you know on polanski i mean
it's a it is a very controversial figure
polanski he is technically well a
fugitive in a child rapist well aside
from
yeah i don't know much about that
because he never went to court and there
were a lot of people that
uh
told their side of the story where
where he already had taken off so well
he did he didn't go to court he didn't
get a call mickey he got convicted and
then he has gone
i didn't know all about that i only know
about
working with him as a director and
it being
one of my most pleasurable
experiences acting ever and if i if i
could work with him one or two times i
would really be
very fortunate and very happy
i loved i loved i loved working with him
it doesn't it doesn't bother you that he
fled justice
no
really
yeah
i mean would you work for somebody like
harvey weinstein for example
knowing what you know now
uh
i turned down a couple jobs from harvey
weinstein
uh
but i worked with him uh
i
i can't answer that
what's the moment mickey of your entire
career that if i had the ability to
let you relive it now
you would choose to relive
my career my life your career well i'll
come to your life as well but first your
career
i did a movie once that i was i they
paid me a lot of
enormous amount of money
and i was ashamed of doing it
i was a shame that i sold out and that's
when i left
acting went back to fighting for six
years and
so i really regretted doing this one
particular movie because they paid me a
lot of money and i went and bought a big
house and all that
which was the movie
harley davidson and the marlborough man
and if you had your time again you just
wouldn't do it
absolutely
i loved working with don johnson it was
just the
i didn't like the material or the the
director was a
can i say
[Laughter]
what's next mickey what do you want to
achieve
you're a guy you said you're in your
third your third act now where are you
yeah the beginning first of all i'm
moving to texas
i think that's going to be really good
for me to be in a place where i i i
don't know i could be around horses
which i love and
i can
get myself very focused i can stay keep
myself in really good physical shape and
uh mental shape is uh
i've always kept my spirituality
very private but it's a very strong part
of my life
what do i want to do now and i and i
started doing this about two years ago
was when i get an opportunity to work
i do
i want to do the best job
in that
moment
that i could ever possibly give the
director
to do
in other words i'm not going to walk
through it i'm going to give him
everything i got
because
from now on every job i get they're
going to get all of me
what does it take mickey to be a truly
great actor
i think a lot of hard work and
discipline
and to be able to be brave enough to
make choices that are interesting
choices that are either going to be
really really good
or terrible
and the other question i wanted to ask
you what was it like to party with tupac
we never saw the daylight
i
i don't i mean i love him i miss him
daily you know
we were very similar
we had a lot of stuff in common
uh
and we we loved each other you know
deeply
and uh
i think about them all the time do you
yeah all the time
i know on a weekly basis practically
yeah you seem mickey and i don't want us
to sound patronizing but you seem
happier than i've known you for a while
more content in your own skin perhaps
well you know i think for for some
strange reason the
the year and a half that i didn't leave
my house
and i brought all my weight equipment
and all my boxing equipment
and i isolated myself for a year and a
half
it helped me
kind of get centered about
my priorities and and to
the worst thing anybody can get is
bitter
and that's the one thing i said i would
never get
i remember several years ago being at
the canfield festival and there was an
actor who used to be a movie star but
not anymore and all he was doing was
bad-mouthing
some actor and i was listening to him
going
besides the fact that you're a junkie
and an alcoholic
here you are badmouthing this guy
and it's like you're just a bitter
and i go i never want to get like that
you know people say to me what's your
best film
and i say i haven't made it yet
which is a great answer because it shows
that you look forward not back right
oh yeah
yeah with both hands
when you do finally have to look back
because you're no longer with us how
would you like to be remembered you
could write your own tombstone and he
said here lies mickey rook he
i don't really care to be remembered
that way
really you don't want to be remembered
at all
that's not relevant to me
i'm looking forward to when i go to
heaven and i can see
where most of my friends are now
well some of them are in hell but i mean
i'm looking i'm looking forward to the
the next journey i mean i don't fear
death
i fear dying but i don't fear death
because
i truly believe it's going to be
like a big happy reunion who are you
most looking forward to seeing up in
heaven most of all my brother my little
my younger brother
joe
joey
my grandmother
my father
some aunts and uncles i didn't get to
know uh
tupac
good good good looking thomas uh
like to meet steve mcqueen paul newman
all those guys monty cliff
you know so i i mean
there's more people that i love
i mean
the older you get the more people around
you die i mean you know two months ago
ray leota was alive and two weeks ago
jimmy khan was alive i mean
i miss willie deville one of my favorite
singers you know
and it's like uh
i've got more people you know gone than
here so it's like
you know
i'm just that's just another journey
that i'm looking forward to
well so am i mickey it's been fantastic
to interview you thank you so much for
all your time i really appreciate it
okay thank you very much
bless you all the best here
you see that's what i call an interview
that's the kind of interview i want on
piers morgan uncensored because he's
uncensored that's the real mickey rook
water and all good bad sometimes ugly
but actually fascinating and compelling
wasn't it
and that's how i would like my movie
stars to be
that's how i'd like everybody to be
just say what's on your mind and don't
worry about it better out than in as my
grandmother used to say
you